in case it's not clear tele operation
means you're controlling the truck
remotely like it's a video game
so uh
you got the chance to witness it does it
actually work
yeah i mean so it's uh what are the pros
and cons you know one of the problems
with with doing research like this with
with all these with all these silicon
valley folks are the ndas
all right
right so so i don't know i don't know
what i'm able to say uh about sort of
watching it but obviously the their
public statements about sort of what the
challenges are right and it's about the
the latency
and the ability to sort of in real time
there's challenges that let me say one
thing uh so i'm talking to the the
you know i've talked to the waymo cto
i'm in conversations with them talking
to the the head of trucking boris uh
sofman
in next month actually i'm a huge fan of
his because he was uh i think the
founder of anki which is a toy robotics
company
so i love cute
i love human robot interaction and he
created one of the most
effective and beautiful
toy robots
anyway i keep complaining to them on
email privately
that uh
there's way too much marketing in these
conversations and not enough showing off
the both the challenge and the beauty of
the engineering efforts and that seems
to be the case for a lot of these
silicon valley tech companies they they
put up this uh you're talking about ndas
they they've i for some reason
rightfully wrongfully
because there's been so much hype and so
much money being made
they don't see the um
the upside in
being transparent and educating the
public about how difficult the problem
is
it's much more effective for them to say
we have everything solved this will
change everything this will change
society as we know and just kind of wave
their hands as opposed to exploring
together like these different scenarios
what are the pros and cons why is it
really difficult
you know what are the what are the gray
areas of where it works and doesn't uh
what's the role of the human in this
picture of the both the sort of the
operators and the other humans on the
road all of that which are fascinating
human
problems fascinating engineering
problems that i wish we could have a
conversation about as opposed to uh
always feeling like it's just marketing
talk because a lot of what we're talking
about now
even you with having private
conversations under nda
you still don't have the full picture
of everything of how difficult this
problem is one of the
big questions i've had still have is how
difficult is driving i disagree with you
know elon musk and jim keller on this
point
i have a sense that driving is
really difficult
you know the task of driving just
broadly this is like philosophy talk
how
how much intelligence is required
to drive a car
so from a like a jim keller who used to
be the head of autopilot
the idea is that it's just a collision
avoidance problem it's like billiard
balls
it's like you have to convert the drive
you have to do some basic perception a
computer vision to convert driving into
a game of pool and then you just have to
get everything into a pocket yeah to me
there seems to be some game theoretic
dance
combined with the fact that people's
life is at stake and then when people
die at the hands of a robot the reaction
is going to be much more complicated so
all of that but that's still an open
question and the cool thing is all of
these companies
are struggling with this question
of of how difficult is it to solve this
problem sufficiently such that we can
build the business on top of it and have
a product that's going to make a huge
amount of money and compete with the
manually driven
uh vehicles and so their tele operation
from starsky is really interesting idea
how much can uh i mean there's a few
autonomous vehicle companies that tried
to integrate operation in the picture
can we
reduce some of the costs
while still having reliability
like uh
uh catch when the vehicle uh fails by
having tele operation it's an open
question
uh so
that's that's for you scenario number
two is to uh use teleoperation as part
of the picture yeah let me let me follow
up on that question of how hard driving
is because this this becomes a big
question for researchers who are
thinking about labor market impacts
right because
we start from a perspective of what's
hard or easy for humans right
and so
you know if you were to look at truck
driving prior to a lot i mean there's
been a lot of thinking and debate in um
in academic you know research circles
around sort of how you estimate labor
impacts right what these models look
like and a lot of it is about how
automatable is a job object recognition
really easy for people right really hard
for computers and so there's a whole
bunch of things that you know truck
drivers do
that we see as you know
super easy and as it would have been
characterized 10 years ago routine and
it's not for a computer right it's a
it's it turns out to be something that
we do naturally that is that is you know
sort of cutting edge right um computer
science
so on the tally operation question i
think this is um
this is a more interesting one than than
people would like to sort of let on i
think publicly
um
they're gonna be problems right um and
this is one of the complexities of sort
of putting these things out in the world
and if if you see the real world of
trucking you realize
wow it's rough you know there are dirt
lots there's gravel there's salt and ice
and cold weather and there's equipment
that just gets left out in the middle of
nowhere and the brakes don't get
maintained and somebody was supposed to
service something and they didn't you
know
and so you imagine okay we've got this
vehicle that can drive itself which is
going to require a whole lot of sensors
to tell it that like the doors are still
closed and the trailers still hooked up
and each of the tires has adequate
pressure and you know
any number of you know probably hundreds
of sensors that are going to be sort of
relaying information
and one of them
you know after 500 000 miles or whatever
goes out
now you know do we have some fleet of
technicians sort of continually cruising
the highways and sort of servicing these
things as they do what pull themselves
off to the side of the road and say i've
got a sensor fault i'm pulling over you
know or maybe there's some level of like
critical safety critical faults or or
whatever
it might be so you know that
suggests that there might be a role for
teleoperation even with self-driving and
when i push people on it in in the
conversations they all are like yeah we
kind of have that on the like bottom of
the list figure out how to rescue truck
you know what gets like on the to-do
list right after solving the
self-driving you know question is like
yeah what do we do with the problems
right i mean now we could we can imagine
like all right we have some you know
protocol that the truck is not you know
realizes the system says not safe for
operation pull to the side
good you have a crash but now you got a
truck stranded on the side of the road
you're gonna send out somebody to like
calibrate things and check out what's
going on or that sounds like expensive
labor it sounds like downtime it sounds
like the kind of things that shippers
don't like to happen to their freight
you know in a in a just-in-time world
and so wouldn't it be great if you could
just sort of you know loop your way into
the
controls of that truck and say all right
we've got a sensor out says me that says
that the tire's bad but i can see
visually from the camera looks fine i'm
going to drive it to our next depot you
know maybe the next rider or penske
location right sort of all these service
locations around and have a tech nation
technician take a look at it so
tally operation often gets this you know
um
dismissive
um
you know commentary from from other
folks working on other other scenarios
but i think it's it's potentially more
relevant than than
than we hear publicly but it's a hard
problem
and uh
you know for me
i've gotten a chance to interact with
people that take on hard problems and
solve them and they're rare what tesla
has done
with their data engine
so i thought autonomous driving cannot
be solved
without collecting a huge amount of data
and organizing the wall not just
collecting but organizing it
and exactly what tesla is doing now is
what i thought it would be like i
couldn't see car companies doing that
including tesla
and now that they're doing that it's
like oh okay so it's possible to take on
this huge effort seriously to me tele
operation is another
huge effort like that
it's like taking seriously
what happens when it fails
what's the in the case of waymo for um
for the consumer like ride sharing
what's the customer experience like
there's a bunch of videos online now
where people are like the car fails and
it pulls off to the side and you call
like customer service and you're
basically sitting there for a long time
and there's confusion and then there's a
rescue that comes and they start to i
mean just the whole experience is a mess
that has a ripple effect
to how you trust in in the entirety of
the experience but like actually taking
on the problem of that failure case
and revolutionizing that experience both
for trucking and for ride sharing that's
an amazing opportunity there because
that
feels like it would change everything
if you can reliably know when the
failures happen which they will you have
a clear plan that doesn't
significantly affect the efficiency of
the whole process
that that could be the game changer
and if tele operation is part of that it
could be just like you're saying it
could be tele operation or it could be
like a fleet of rescuers that can come
in which is a similar idea but tele
operation obviously
that allows you to
to just have a network of monitors of
people monitoring this giant fleet of
trucks and taking over when needed it's
a beautiful vision of the future where
there's
millions of robots
and only thousands of humans monitoring
those millions of robots
that seems like
that seems like a perfect dance
of allowing humans to do what they do
best and allowing robots to do what they
do best
yeah yeah so i mean i think there are um
and we just applied for an nsf we didn't
get
anybody's watching
but with some folks from wisconsin who
do teleoperation right and and you know
some of this is used for like rovers and
you know i mean really you know high
stakes difficult problems but one of the
things we wanted to study were these
mines in these rio tinto mines in
australia where
they remotely pilot the trucks and
there's some autonomy i guess and then
but it's overseen by
um a remote operator and they
you know it's a it's a it's near perth
and it's it's quite remote and
um
they retrained the truck drivers to be
the remote operators right um there's
autonomy in in the port of rotterdam and
places like that where there are jobs
there and so there i think
you know maybe we'll get to this later
but you know there's a real policy
question about sort of
who's going to lose and what we do about
it and you know whether or not we there
are opportunities there that you know
maybe we need to put our thumb on the
scale a little bit to to make sure that
you know there there's some give back to
the community that's that's taking the
hit you know um so for instance if there
were tally operation centers you know
maybe they go in these communities that
we disproportionately source truck
drivers from today now i mean what does
that mean it may not be the cheapest
place to do it if they don't have great
connectivity and it may not be where the
upper level managers want to be and you
know places like that you know the
issues like that right so
um i do think it's an interesting
question you know both from sort of a
practical
uh scenario situation of how it's going
to work
but also from a policy perspective so
there's platoons there's tele operation
and this is uh taking care of some of
the highway driving that we're talking
about is there other ideas like
um
is there other ideas scenarios that you
have for autonomous trucks yeah so i
mean the the most obvious one actually
is is just you know uh facility to
facility right this sort of you know um
it can't go everywhere but a lot of
logistics facilities are very close to
interstates and they're and they're on
big commercial roads without you know
bikes and parked cars and all that stuff
and some of the jobs that i think are
really first on the chopping block
are these ltl that less than truckload
what's called line haul right so these
are the drivers who go from terminal to
terminal with those full trailers
um and those facilities are often
located strategically to avoid
congestion right um and to be in big you
know industrial facilities so
you could imagine that being you know
the first place you see a waymo
self-driving you know truck roll out
might be you know um sort of direct
facility to facility for ups or fedex or
less than truckload care and the idea
there is fully driverless so potentially
not even a driver in the truck
it's just going from facility to
facility
empty zero occupancy yeah and those
because that labor is expensive uh you
know they don't keep those drivers out
overnight those drivers do do a run back
and forth typically or in a team to go
back and forth in in one day
so from the people you've spoken with uh
so far what's your sense how far are we
away from which scenario is closest and
how far away are we from that scenario
of autonomy
being a big part of our trucking fleet
most folks are are focused on another
scenario which is the exit to exit right
which looks like that urban truck ports
um
thing that i laid out earlier you know
so you have a human-driven truck that
comes out to um a drop lot it meets up
with an autonomous truck the
that truck then you know drives it on
the interstate to another lot and then a
human driver um
you know picks it up
there are a couple variations maybe on
that um
so
or let me just run through the last two
scenarios sure
the other thing you could do right is to
say all right i've got a truck that can
drive itself um and i refer to this one
as autopilot but
you know you have a human drive it out
to the interstate but rather than have
that transaction where where the human
driven truck detaches the trailer and it
gets coupled up to a self-driving truck
they just that human
driver just hops on the interstate with
that truck and goes in back and goes off
duty while the truck drives itself and
and so you have a self-driving truck
that's not driverless right um
and just to clarify because tesla uses
the term autopilot and so the airplanes
and so everybody uses the word autopilot
we're referring to essentially full
autonomy but because it's exit to exit
the truck driver is
on board the truck but they're sleeping
in the back or whatever yeah and this
this gets to the really weedy policy
questions right so basically for the
department of transportation for you to
be off duty for safety reasons you have
to be completely relieved of all
responsibility
so that truck has to not you know
encounter a construction
site or what inclement weather or
whatever it might be
and and call to you and say hey you know
or i mean obviously right we're
imagining connected vehicles as well
right so
you're in a self-driving truck you're in
the back and trucks 20 miles ahead
experience some problem right um that
may require tele operation or whatever
it is right and it signals to your truck
hey you know tell the driver 20 miles
ahead he's he's got to hop in the seat
that would mean that they're on duty
according to the way that the current
rules are written they have some
responsibility and part of that is you
know we need we need them to get rest
right
they need to have uninterrupted
sleep
you